There are over 2 billion school-aged
individuals living in the world today.
That's more young people than any
other time in human history.
And it's this generation's creativity,
their actions,
their art,
their poetry,
their protests,
their questions,
their code,
their dreams.
It's this generation's ideas that will
define the future of our world.
One well articulated idea
can reach and inspire millions.
That's why TED's youth
and education initiative, TED-Ed,
has created a program
that's dedicated to sparking
and celebrating the best ideas
of young people around the world.
"The essence of TED-Ed was to create
more confident individuals."
"It was our club;
it was run by us and for us."
The program is called TED-Ed Clubs.
It supports students in identifying
their passions,
learning public speaking skills,
connecting with a global
network of classrooms,
and sharing student ideas
in the form of short, TED-style talks.
Here's how it works.
Participating students and teachers gain
access to a free and flexible curriculum
they can use to start a TED-Ed Club
at their school.
Each suggested meeting uses TED Talks
to help students engage
in critical thinking exercises
and gain invaluable presentation skills.
In the final meeting, students are invited
to give their own TED Talk,
and if they record their Talk,
they can upload it
to TED-Ed's award-winning platform,
where it can be referenced on a résumé,
a college application,
and shared with participating clubs
around the world.
Over 2 billion young people empowered
and encouraged to share their ideas.
Imagine that future
and bring TED-Ed Clubs
to your community today.